three days Posey and Kaitlyn Kaitlyn now
where you guys from Chicago Illinois
Chicago pulling us out here
the tuna have used 20 years in LA and
then how long it's get rough or close
are know the hole in LA for two and a
half years in Skid Row we'd probably be
seven months right yes six
not two we used to stay in MacArthur
Park not much better yeah
[Music]
kind of same scene which words yeah
that's an homage now take the same God
there's that more gang activity over
there yeah here's less it incorporated
and you guys are on the street yes how
long even in the cold on the street
me personally just this whole time and
like forever a good decade on and off
I've got a bunch of yeah I've gotten a
bunch of apartment soon you know I
really taking my time to enjoy him sucks
that you started believe God you know
conditioned living you know I mean
advice for the air conditioner and stuff
and then I get hungry for the road you
know I'm before all other things that
traveler I'm not really a like I don't
feel like like sticking to one spot is
really my style we've just uh I only got
shackled by a few things kind of here
and also comfortably it's it's more its
kind of comfortable in a way that's all
they got us a little bit stuck yeah
my friends and beyond this romantic
adventure and the cons of addiction and
whatnot
what's your drug of choice antara what
go together yeah
the heroines a bad one yeah now it's
just straight fentanyl
we don't even bother it there one part
anymore we just smoke convos it yeah
it's crazy because it's more it's more
but more involved in such more automated
than even intravenous Evans we just
smoked and it's like you know any easy
crackheads on the street
and you think like all cracks like
probably like those people are the worst
people
fentanyl makes you well worst crackhead
and crack does I think if that makes
sense
I can't see it I can't say it's not
without its beautiful parts though what
were they up were the upsides of I mean
just start the time that I spend with
her and little monk magic moments to get
you know that I kind of and completely
Transport started is you know it's so
like kind of like an intoxicating my
gold fairy tale of its own you know 28
29 30 30 30
yeah I just wanted to make one where
would you guys were you guys like to see
yourself in five years almost exactly
where I was like three years ago were
really cool apartment was really good
people and stuff like that I kind of
just saw I got a tiny smudge of let me
go trouble I guess much seriously and
what kind of trouble I just had LSD in
Chicago which holds an eight-year
sentence yeah but uh you know that I
really just had like a little drug
charge that snowballs and I just had to
do drug classes for it I can never
complete them so I kept getting locked
out
yo yo process knowing now what I find
you then what I know now I probably
would just face the music president to
take prison time or whatever but he kept
using probation I'd be like 60 days
that's like it's what age were you guys
did drugs for the first time like well
officially I'd say 16 what drug is that
now that's the yeah that's T and then I
also did I mean I tried here on 16 as
well
we don't know I I started with decay we
tried weed and shot wait until I was
really no god but like thousand I was
like fifteen and I didn't do any
hardcore drugs until I'm basically my
you probably it's not your fault it's
just like Kurt crew we were anyhow is
the good install ready annex I cried for
three months I was like can you please
just smoke weed today guys and they were
already completely in the whatsit I
didn't start doing that use either and
so we started dating but yeah good guy
did you snowballs so quickly but they
said tell me but your your chocolate
your family no I came into the country
at age 3 my father's like a reporter in
El Salvador correspondents worked for
Time magazine and stuff covering the war
out there is named after Oscar Romero
the Archbishop of El Salvador at the
time was assassinated it's like a close
friend of my family's and stuff
and yeah I don't know then my mom were
true like all of our assets were seized
by the Salvadorian government we fled to
Mexico fled to this country my mom
worked to build a life for us and when I
was like 11 she kind of like you know
had everything put together
we just continued but a my brother in
hurt my brother died and it was pretty
it was pretty perfect I'm not a lot I
worked it worked good I really love him
really yeah
bye either
[Music]
well my mom had me out of wedlock when I
was three she married my stepdad her
floor she married my stepdad and when I
was like 10 ish my mom moved to Chicago
she got pregnant with twins my little
brother and sister they were my stuff
siblings but really they're just my
siblings and my stepdads are really just
my dad
my stepdads like kind of an [ __ ] you
never drank or anything you just had
like habitual verbal abuse problems
mostly every came physical when I was
like 11 with you yeah and that you know
like I grew up in a really really nice
community on the North Shore of Chicago
and that just threw me into sort of like
like a rebellious it's like phase I
guess um and so saying starting out the
wrong crowd or so to speak because the
kids without dad's club
I guess the Lost Boys yeah stuff like
that oh no bad I had a really good
family too I didn't come from you know
anything dirt poor or anything like
super bad No
[Music]
but
I think I'm not I'm not really sure all
right you guys are happy with your
situation right now at all not at all we
want to quit every day we get in fights
over it all the time he just found a
rehab that Medicare doesn't pay for
medical like withdrawal we legal details
yeah we need a medical detox going
through detox is rehabs like not going
through them physically just like
calling it on the internet uh where are
you I'm physically gone through like one
and a half no no but in Chicago
going to a couple rehabs but that was
another seventeen super and different
about the results yeah you see what the
future is down the road for this right
yeah its energy and then I knew when I
watched arrive again for a dream where I
was kind of in a sense signing up for
but now there's a big part of me that is
growing glowing and like kind of trying
to take back the steering wheel of my
life you know and build something build
a builder nice for us
good luck with that thank you so much
for talking to me
that's lutely okay they're easy to talk
to yeah I'll give you a ride back to
your place thank you